so good afternoon everyone and thank you
for being here and it's really
a pleasure to welcome you to this
semester's women of Yale lecture we
began this series a couple of years ago
to showcase the accomplishments of women
who graduated from Yale and our guests
including our distinguished speaker
today Kiara cuties represent the very
best of this university and they reflect
the remarkable success of co-education
at Yale my wife Marta Barret who is also
a woman of Yale a 1984 graduate of our
public health school she's actually the
one who first proposed the idea of a
speaker series that would bring back to
Yale some of the most inspiring women
and to do it in this year or leading up
to this year the year in which we
celebrate the 50th anniversary of
co-education and young in yell college
and it's been a fantastic way to meet
and hear from some of our most brilliant
and accomplished alumni these events
have been able have allowed us to
commemorate the legacy of women at this
university to learn about their
leadership their contributions to
society and you'll recall our first
speaker was Maya Lin a pioneering
architect who graduated from Yale
College in 1981 earned her master's
degree from the school of architecture
in 1986 and returned a year later to
receive an honorary Doctor of Fine Arts
degree from Yale after that we welcomed
Vera wells who is here today sitting
right here she was a member of the class
of 1971 the first Yale College
graduating class to include women and
she was the recipient of the Yale medal
for service to the University and we
honored Anita Hill a lawyer scaled
trailblazer and scholar and advocate for
women's rights she graduated from the
Yale Law School in 1980 and then last
year we heard from dr. Patricia Nez
Henderson she is the first name
of American women to graduate from the
Yale School of Medicine and she earned
her master's degree in public health
from Yale as well so as we celebrate
these women pioneers we need to remember
that actually women have been at Yale as
students longer than the fifty years in
Yale College the School of Art when it
first opens its doors 150 years ago
women and men studied together so it's
fitting that we met we welcome today
Kiara cuties who was a 1999 graduate of
Yale College but is a playwright author
from West Philly with roots in Puerto
Rico and boricua and he shows us because
she studies it and the importance of
Arts in our world her plays and musicals
I don't have to tell you about them
they've been performed around the world
they include Elliott a soldiers few
finalist for the Pulitzer Prize water by
the spoonful winner of the 2012 pill
Enterprise for drama and the Tony
award-winning Broadway hit in the
heights we were actually talking before
the this program about our families she
lives in the heights and I have an uncle
who was in the heights and my nephew
lives in the heights and so sharing
tales of the neighborhood Charles
Isherwood of the New York Times
described in the heights as a panoramic
portrait of a New York neighborhood
filled with spanish-speaking dreamers of
American Dreams nervously eyeing their
futures from a city block on the cusp of
change this Hootie's has adapted her
award-winning work for the screen and is
in release this summer right at movie
theaters all across the country
her most recent musical miss you like
hell
ran off Broadway at the Public Theater
and she has written a memoir which will
be published next year by one world
Random House she's the co-founder
emancipated stories a platform for
incarcerated people to share their
stories through writing and art and we
are so grateful that you are here with
us today so grateful that you share your
story with us today she will speak to us
about art and disruption and I ask you
to join me in welcoming Kiara hello how
y'all doing I'm tempted to start by
going off script and see who would be
willing let's let's get a little
physical for a second so two parts to
this because this is gonna be like a
bedtime story that I'm about to do even
though it's before everyone's bedtime
but so it's hard to give a bedtime story
that far back so if anyone feels
compelled to come a little bit closer to
me so I can kind of like look you in the
eye while telling this bedtime story I
would welcome that no pressure if you're
comfortable stay where you are but if
you want to come up so I can really
connect with you the closer the better
so I'll give you a moment to do that but
then I'm gonna ask everyone also
wherever you are to get a little
physical
oh it means people are sitting closer to
each other I like this and I'm gonna be
doing a Q&A at the end of my remarks so
if anything any thoughts come up that
you're interested in discussing I know
there's some students here who are
interested in incarceration topics
possibly you know just things that come
to mind just flag it because we'll have
time to to open up the conversation at
the end okay so I think before I started
I learned this from an activist I met in
Philadelphia I'm gonna turn off my mic I
just to connect us in the room I'm gonna
ask everyone to start by screaming I'm
not not so that you hurt your throat not
so that you hurt your neighbor but just
just to give the room our energy as the
collective to just be energetic in the
room together I know it sounds a little
strange I'm gonna join you in the scream
so I think seated is okay I don't want
to ask you all to do too much but but if
you'll take the leap of faith it's not
gonna like blow anyone's ears out it's
actually almost like a strange sort of
like prayer or something cool you guys
trust me enough to give it a try so
we're just gonna scream for a second all
right all right ready here we go one two
three
whoo thank you
all right least for my mic back on okay
so here we go
wait I might okay got a lot of mics so
so this thing I'm about to do called art
and disruption is based on years of
conversations with Cory Menifee here in
New Haven over the last four years but
mostly in 2016 I paraphrase just a tiny
amount and the only editing is for
clarity and continuity Corey's here and
I want to thank him from the bottom of
my heart the rest of my presentation is
pulled right out of my life so I took
liberties with that but it's all true
also shouting out and really bodies who
designed my PowerPoint slides it's
mostly art from children's books that
she messed with that she broke or
disrupted so art and disruption all
right so I thought I'd tell a tale spin
a yarn kind of like circle time story
hour a night night book about an
ordinary guy and an ordinary girl came
of age in the 80s and 90s listening to
some of the tunes you heard while
walking in he from the African American
Hill section of New Haven she from West
Philly and North Philly El Barrio
birthda Rico and Philadelphia and a
moment that they crossed paths at Yale I
even went a soft style and wrote a moral
at the end of the story
so that was actually my prologue let's
go okay
once upon a time a child named cauri
lived on Orchard Street but would hang
on Kensington then he moved to Sheffield
Ave then Lake place where his family had
more room every three to five years
Cory moved to a different house on those
New Haven's streets Cory would ride
bikes play basketball get up with his
buddies young carefree going with the
flow at four or five or six he took to
the New York Giants because blue was his
favorite color or because he was
watching with his grandfather and older
uncles who were all Giants fans either
way he loved all teams that wore blue
Michigan football the Mets Hillhouse
High he always rooted for Hill House
over cross for winter holidays his
family split into two sides on one side
his mother's mother's branch was how to
put this middle-class you wore your good
shirt in time you sat around the table
and said a prayer and if there was music
playing it was violins you ate
Thanksgiving or Christmas dinner at 1:00
or 2:00 in the afternoon then he would
go to the menifee side to Pao house his
father's father was Pao Pao that side
was more urban he'd put on his jeans and
hoodie there was going to be loud music
dancing playing spades yelling and
screaming over the movies on July 4th
they would get up before sunrise and go
to Wharton Brooke both sides of the
family together Cory would stay guarding
the picnic table while the elders parked
and unpacked the food there was always a
deck of cards for playing spades running
back and forth to the beach rolling down
dirt hills
that's how Cory passed the time with the
other kids stuff that now he's like man
that was dumb his two grandmother is
Plus Aunt Gladys cooking the day away
his mom was on macaroni and cheese duty
pow-pow worked the grill there would
always be a pot of rice cabbage or
string beans chicken or pork chops a
baked ham sweet potatoes corn bread
lasagna the
all works after his mom's vision when
Corey became her eyes in the kitchen
that's how he learned to cook elbows
extra sharp cheddar a stick of butter
two eggs
American cheese but to this day his mac
and cheese never comes out quite the
same the love she put into it
caring and sympathetic nice kind-hearted
but she couldn't cuss your ass out in a
heartbeat a strong spirited woman that
was his mom's personality he became
independent like her not liking to
depend on nobody for nothing history and
social studies were his best subjects
because it's a matter of memorization
you just cram the facts into your brain
the school laid out two possible paths
you could be like w eb de boys who
believed that black people should take
on professional roles like dr. professor
lawyer they should use their mind to
give back a mindset Cory would embrace
years later at college or you could be a
Booker T Washington guy cast your
buckets down here learn a trade gain
practical skills after college in his
20s he would become a Booker T guy Koree
it was said possessed an ability pow-pow
had he could walk with kings and bums
alike plus he got pow pow schematic
intelligence being in a bad mood around
Corey was hard in second grade the
teacher called his mom and said Corey
does his work he's a good student but
he's the class clown he likes to goof
around well his mom came into school and
whupped him right there with all the
kids laughing she gave away his lunchbox
and his backpack she and Corey lived
with pow-pow at the time and he kicked
her out for a minute he was mad but she
had high expectations of her son when
Corey was 10 his mom got pregnant as a
diabetic she was put on strict bed rest
it was on Corey to do things now push a
cart full of clothes down the hill learn
how to operate a washing machine
the laundromat bring the list of
groceries and money to the store and do
the shopping when she went into labor
the doc said this baby's gonna die to
see Cory's sister had been premature and
died at birth his brother William also
premature died at birth but this time
the docs were wrong
Corey became a big brother the love of
his life
that's what Mitchell became Cory fed him
changed him handed him off to a girl to
go play street ball his mom would say I
had Mitchell just for you but Cory was
bad she'd make threats you're out of my
will
you're not getting Mitch 7th grade girls
began to develop Cory fell in love with
a different one every day a girl would
randomly smile say hello and Cory would
think oh my god I love her he had no
skills whatsoever but high aspirations
and the girls that liked him he didn't
like them back so he went to the
eighth-grade dance alone in high school
he was a brain biggie smalls wu-tang
that's what he liked his hillside
friends let him hang but pushed him
aside when it came to came to extremes
drugs beefing the Trey guys they'd
always be beefing with hillside now this
ain't for you his friend said they could
have seduced him into it but they had
that type of love for him but once
walking home at 1:00 in the morning he
ran into some guy he some guys he knew a
Trey guy was like where you from Cory
said the hill guy had a gun on him said
you should run but Cory being young and
cocky was like I'm gonna run just
walking away slowly stop shot started
going off one ricocheted off his shoe
this guy was shooting everything but
Cory then was like turn around turn
around and when Cory did he put that gun
right up on Cory's chest click he had
run out of bullets
later that night Cory was just thanking
God
counting the bullet holes in his pants
the the style was real baggy back then
it dawned on Cory he really tried to
shoot me duh that's how he learned don't
go around saying you're from any
neighborhood since he didn't have
something on his hip to protect him
instead of beefing he went to play
practice cast as Atticus Finch in To
Kill a Mockingbird missing rehearsal
only for football practice even though
he stunk to quote him I had a mixed
skillset that didn't relate to success
on the field he could catch but he
wasn't fast he was a very under sized
offensive lineman anyone after two or
three years of this going to practice
every day faithfully not getting any
play time would have quit but Cory stuck
with it he loved football later in life
if he said he played in high school his
uncle would correct him you were on the
team senior prom this time he had a date
last dance of the night was Keith Sweat
make it last forever
college tuition would be tight his
mother had been a home health aide what
they called private duty she had worked
11 through 7 then at a factory but she
became disabled the result of juvenile
diabetes
she lost a toe went blind seeing only
blurry shapes and light with no money in
his pocket
Cory headed down to Virginia Union
University stole books from the
bookstore went homeless for an entire
semester meaning he was an off-campus
student meaning he couldn't eat in the
dining hall so he would steal from
grocery stores things he wasn't proud of
but the journalism major taught him to
write to choose a subject to qualify the
story and talk to both both parties tell
it from both aspects graduation came in
the early aughts the same year his mom
died the night before her passing she
coughed and sneezed really hard she
went to the bathroom on herself okay so
not number two just wet he said I have
to change you she resisted wanted to
rest he said all right next morning she
was unresponsive sugar level almost on a
coma Cory called an ambulance and while
they came he changed his mother's
underwear that's a very hard thing for a
man to do no Ann wants to change his
mother's underwear but she couldn't go
to the emergency room like that for
years that's how long it took Cory to
read the Bible cover-to-cover
he set a goal and accomplished it
finished in June of 2015
admittedly he skipped around a little
bit his favorite verse was Philippians
chapter 4 verse 13 anyone know how long
I can do all things through Christ for
it is he who strengthens me
he told me you can read something and
you can even comprehend what it's saying
but until it applies to your life you
don't know for example he was going over
to Whitney Avenue to bid on a Yale
dining hall job he had to be at work at
Davenport by 11:30 but by the time he
finished his bid paperwork
it was already 11:15 mind you he walks
with a limp from a long ago car accident
and he was like how am I going to get
there so he recited the verse and
started walking I can do all things
through Christ for it is he who
strengthens me
I can do all things through Christ for
it is me who strengthens and for it is
he who strengthens me he swiped in at
11:30 precisely from the get-go when his
mother-in-law introduced him to her
manager the Yale job felt like family
and the pay was good take out the trash
work in the dish room keep the floors
clean compost that is separate the food
waste from the other trash sometimes
doing the same task for weeks and weeks
get stale so every once in a while the
workers would switch it up
often they shared a family meal sat down
together and ate the food that they had
cooked healthy meals vegan dishes a
salad bar and Cory being diabetic that
worked for him the backbone of Yale
University that's how he described his
coworkers without staff and those behind
the scenes the university couldn't drive
there'd be chaos if the students came to
eat and we weren't there Cory said and
he loved the work one simple hi how you
doing could mean a big difference to a
student seeing people every day they
opened up he was invited to a gospel
choir performance at Patel Chapel tired
at the end of his shift he wanted to go
home instead after a hard day of work
the gospel choir was refreshing
the girl who invited him was in tears
told him I view you as a father figure
he knew some of these students were
thousands of miles away from everyone
they knew and loved
he remembered being in their shoes at
Virginia Union that they might not have
anyone around to reassure them so that
being able to open up say yeah it's been
a hard week might help them we have a
lot of fun at work Cory told me but our
main concern is to attend to students
and I take that very seriously he said
oh and one more detail before I end part
one of this story when Cory was 16 miss
Manila his Spanish teacher held him
after class she said Cory you're a
straight kid you follow the rules one
day you're gonna have to learn how to
break a rule his mother always instilled
do the right thing and now an authority
figure was like learned to break a rule
his mind was blown once upon a time
there was a place called Yale beautiful
buildings were connected by stone paths
cast iron gates and border walls of
sturdy masonry each room was full of
many curious hearts Souls hungry to
learn
Yale owned so many gorgeous buildings
and artworks that one might say beauty
was its property sterling library alone
had two thousand unique stained-glass or
printed glass panels fitting for an
institution whose Latin motto meant
truth and light Reunion Weekend 2016 a
Sunday in May 11:30 a.m. the Calhoun
dining staff had completed its work for
the day cleaning up after the reunions
ended Cory was thinking should I leave
now and take half a day because the
shift was supposed to end at 3:00 he
thought well stay till 12:00 to make it
an even number that's when the knock
came at the door no one wanted to open
it they had already finished up but Cory
relented standing there was an
african-american man alongside a girl of
about 10 the stranger said hi I used to
be a student here can I show my daughter
where I used to eat Cory let him in
there in the empty dining hall the
alumnus started telling his daughter
about the removal of names how in his
undergrad years african-american
students like himself wanted the name
Calhoun removed from the college
explaining to his daughter how John C
Calhoun grew up in the late 1700s
believing what his daddy told him that
slavery was a moral good traveling from
the South up to attend Yale how in the
US Senate he opposed abolition and
passionately led the pro-slavery
legislative agenda views he took to the
White House a Secretary of State than
vice president fathertold daughter these
things in this empty dining hall Cory
and the workers heard and at times
joined in the stranger welcomed this he
explained how in his undergraduate years
Yale had removed Calhoun stained-glass
portrait not the whole thing just the
part where an african-american man in
shackles knelt at Calhoun's feet then
father led daughter to the small
stained-glass windows they went in
sequence he explained first a picture of
a tree next a house
next enslaved people picking cotton
corey thought no they don't show that
i've been working here a long time i
ain't seen nothing like that but the
father invited Corey to check it out
this window beneath which he had eaten
his college meals you see the windows
are small and a little high up and
Corey's vision is blurry just like his
mother before him also from diabetes
Corey needed glasses still does so Corey
leaned in close and saw it for the first
time african-americans with cotton bales
on their head one of them smiling
looking peaceful Corey was like oh that
can't be here that's not right no no no
because it was deliberate that these
were african-american people one with a
smile on her face after that when Corey
came into work it was staring at him
eating away at his subconscious like you
think someone's watching you that
feeling of eyes on your back eyes on
your shoulders eyes on your neck
a week later Corey thought that thing
has to come down it was God's work not
planned or premeditated all he wanted
was to get a paycheck and take care of
his family but instead he went and found
a broomstick climbed up on here and
smashed the window panel 27 pieces of
glass fell into the moat outside the
grassy part separating the wall from the
sidewalk inside an old lady said oh the
production manager was like dude you
just destroyed yells property Corey said
it looks a lot better now then headed
for the locker room when he was scruffy
people often disengaged but when he was
clean-shaven and made eye contact
people would say hi first so he went and
shaved as the authorities searched the
building for him a co-worker came into
the locker room like our general manager
was looking for you Corey said I bet she
is the authorities questioned him he was
composed honest Corey told me I'm
stand-up person I really despise liars I
don't understand why people lie all the
time he didn't try to cover anything he
accepted responsibility the sergeant
said yo son I'm gonna have to slap cuffs
on you for this Cory put out his wrist
calm and said ok here you go
as the two arresting officers were
joined by 15 more to investigate the
scene Cory went to jail
resign from the job that was the union
reps advice
Cory agreed to never pursue Yale for a
hostile work environment
Yale agreed not to seek reparations for
their destroyed property and for
emphasis I Chiara will add an editorial
repeat property property Cory signed his
letter of resignation and said ok I'll
move on with my life he didn't want a
felony hanging over his head for
breaking a window the rest is a matter
of public record court record and
google-able
he lost his job was charged with a
felony given a promise to appear
released after 3 hours in custody his
family was all down on him his baby
brother Mitch was like how could you be
so stupid to let a picture on the wall
cause you to lose your job until Cory's
phone started ringing area codes from
Texas North Carolina
it's such-and-such from Fox News from
NBC from Democracy Now after the media
frenzy he went from being the biggest
dumbass in the family to maybe it was
good he did that
still they wanted Cory to do two things
one offer a letter of apology to cry his
soul out and beg for his job back about
the second he told me know about the
first he wrote a five sentence letter of
apology using these skills he'd let
deteriorate throughout the years
expressing each sentence line by line
the word choice the narrative
description he hadn't written since
college there was a big picture of what
he wanted to say I'm sorry for what I
did
now he had five sentences to paint the
picture here is two of them quote I want
to express remorse for my barbaric
actions Yale College I truly do love all
of you end quote
off it went to Calvin College but then
he wondered barbaric action really yes
and no if you destroy something that's
barbaric and it was never a good idea to
destroy property but if he was in that
situation a million times he'd probably
do the same thing a cause a movement was
already in place that had stagnated the
students had been protesting for months
years actually in truth decades to
change the name if Yale didn't listen to
the student body why were they gonna
listen to a blue-collar worker and I
promise you Cory told me if I had just
said something the image would still be
there today
soon Yale dropped the term master for a
new one head of college soon
Yale renamed Calvin College to hopper
Cory told me it makes you wonder why
something so easily resolved becomes so
complex it's almost as though you want
the name the negative buzz he told me it
was an oppressive image that a lot of
people felt ill about seeing on July 26
2016 I attended Cory's second criminal
hearing out on the courthouse steps
black lives matter was present Latinos
Unidos in accion was present
chanting changed the name changed the
name going through security I saw one
guard handing out coffees to her crew
how are they doing out there one ass
there's a whole bunch of protesters out
there chanting it she replied hats off
in the courtroom the court officer
called on one bench a bug-eyed dude
rambled about his cigarette addiction
the stenographer complained about the
judges tardiness sometimes he doesn't
come out till after 11:00 she said
that's why I shouldn't have put my money
in the meter
on another bench Cory sat unmoving the
gait of anticipation the docket began
first a second-degree burglary
next a violation of a protective order
guilty pleas were logged so noted so
ordered annexed all criminal charges
against Cory were dropped when Cory
walked out about half the courtroom
stood and left with him deans and
students had been there all morning in
quiet support outside people had posters
and banners with his name on it
posters that said menifee equals Rosa
Parks news cameras and reporters pounced
do you want your job back one ass and a
protester shouted no he doesn't want a
job from that racist institution
Cory went on record then and there I
want my job back soon Yale went on
record too if he wants his job back we'd
love to have him that's how his dining
hall position was reinstated through the
press that summer Cory attended the
hillside reunion like usual one friend
said a man come over here you know what
you did man we're gonna give you a clap
for that we gonna give you some
recognition walking the streets of New
Haven Cory got nods and thumbs up from
folks even from police little kids I
want to thank you you're a hero when he
returned to Yale a stranger approached
it's good to have you back a dining hall
manager I don't agree with what you did
but as a white man I respect what you
did I understand why you did it
a passerby hey you're the guy who broke
the glass oh man I appreciate what you
did a young lady at Styles where he now
worked you're so awesome and to me as we
sat in a dark bar having the
conversations that led to this tale he
said students had been protesting for
months years about the Calhoun name just
break it you can't live in fear of doing
things once upon a time avianna vase
either of some phrase there was a girl
named Kiara who grew up in Philly
loving art museum art and fancy stuff
sure but street art
especially she had an aunt who played
neoclassical punk at CBGB and would
sneak her into gigs though she was only
5 as her aunt put on thick
bad-to-the-bone eyeliner
the girl was hypnotized by the
vandalized dressing room there was a
neighbour Adi macumba who made
instruments out of garbage performed
street concerts by the tracks on 49th
and Baltimore no venue or cover price
just a kalimba a thumb piano made out of
an old discarded Bustelo can two
teenagers dropped a snare on a West
Philly street corner and started rapping
it was catchy repeated on loop in the
girl's head it looks like another once
coming around past the what passed the
popcorn years later she heard it on
power 99 FM a group called the roots
Reni Harris would produce illud elf
legends showing school kids mr. Wiggles
Crazy Legs Don Campbell they'd be
popping locking whacking voguing and
breaking the girl like all her
classmates got how breaking was creation
graffiti popped up everywhere prettying
up broken walls ugly up pretty walls
street legends like curraghs and
cornbread but the girl didn't know it
then she couldn't make out all the
letters only that a whole lot of them
read our IP clear as day keith haring
defacement became pins on the girls
backpack she saw kathy changed dance on
the art museum steps are over by the
38th Street bridge peace signs on her
flags and face passers-by laughed at the
dancing fool cops arrested her for
breaking the peace when the dancing fool
set herself a flame before the peace
statue when she self-immolated as her
final performance the girl grieved so
many after schools the girl walked to
westco's video and rented the same VHS
tape do the right thing she screamed
when Sal smashed radio Raheem's boombox
to shards so that this girl grew up
thinking the purpose of art was
literally to break things now seeing art
that often led to arrest
surrounded by art crimes it was the 80s
and 90s when crack and AIDS decimated
her away las barrio it was a savage time
in uncertain time they were skeleton
years it was a mayhem epoch around the
girl bodies were breaking buildings and
city blocks were breaking t cells were
breaking runaway daddies left a trail of
the brokenhearted broken window was the
name of the police strategy the art of
the time did not romanticize this girl's
world but made something powerful by
reporting the chaos by reflecting the
eras rupture to this girl
art was transformation not in the gooey
kumbaya sense but in the most igniting
conflictual sense art was a hammer
smashing the material world smashing the
picket fence fairytales she saw on TV
and the girl found solace in that
smashing because there is consolation in
truthfulness even through the discomfort
and in all that broken creation she
discovered deeply that she was not alone
she wasn't alone mourning three family
members felled by AIDS she wasn't alone
missing cousins who disappeared to
addiction or prostitution or prison she
wasn't alone thinking she was a zero
because daddy left she wasn't alone
being blinded with rage when her coz was
blinded by a bullet the girl loved the
honesty of the breaking it made new life
where there had been dereliction then
she went to Yale then she graduated then
her plays went to Broadway she won
prizes and it was easy to mistake the
prestige a Yale degree international
stages Awards for moral soundness and
spiritual success to think that she had
done her work some of her plays were
honest some decent or even good though
she was never sure some she knew but
admit were too well behaved by this time
she had long since become a woman when
the girl hood had left and the woman
hood had dropped in
she couldn't pinpoint but during those
womanhood becoming years 1 cousins HIV
became undetectable another cousin
thrived in the long haul of recovery the
blind cousin learned Braille and got a
PhD sure prison had claimed a few of the
rising young generation but crack
cocaine grip on the bhatia loosened in
fact her body poor cousin in recovery
now cooked free meals for opioid addicts
who were pretty much all white beneath
the same tracks she used to go copping
walking their City ten serving after was
going on due lays out her car trunk
thinking there but for the grace of God
go I the woman's family was perhaps less
broken now the less brokenness brought
tremendous relief it brought true peace
but it was easy to conflate the less
brokenness with moral soundness and
spiritual success to think they had all
done their work then one day the woman
read how Corrie Menifee shattered a
window decorative stained glass showing
slavery as a noble history and the
little girl within her awoke the one who
knew of broken things and the woman for
she had become a woman now wondered if
she would be brave enough to commit that
simple act to break a small window at an
institution that she benefited from so
she took a train to Newhaven to attend a
criminal court hearing and asked Corrie
menifee for permission for the honor of
hearing more and telling it and then I
wrote these words to read to you you
roomful of strangers whom I see with
love tonight and they wrote these words
to Corrie
you quarry right there whom I see with
love and also the complication reserved
for those I respect the most this is my
thank you letter / Aesop's fable for you
the moral of the story is that in
institutions that own beauty that value
pedigree and decorum your truth you out
there today
your truth may be a beautiful disruption
the moral of the story is that there is
no guidebook or checklist no great wise
leader will say go now is the time for
breaking you are the guidebook and the
checklist you are the leader the time to
disrupt is a matter of your gut your
integrity your grace the moral of the
story is as you exist in and beyond Yale
and carry the fraught vaunted name into
true and false powers remember to exist
on your own terms not on anyone else's
the moral of the story is what was the
real stain on the stained glass window
and now that the window is broken is the
real stain removed the moral of the
story is Cory created an empty rectangle
where more light could flow truth
through enlightenment Lux at Veritas by
breaking Yale he bettered Yale the end
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know I was gonna do a QA and see if
anyone had questions and maybe since
Cory's willing and close by if anyone
would you feel comfortable answering any
questions questions for either myself or
Corey could be about this topic or about
whatever is on your mind
I think there were supposed to be
microphones but I don't see them so if
we have microphones okay great
so if anyone has any questions let's
let's chat what's on people's minds
there's one microphone over there oh and
one here sandy has one don't be shy we
all screamed together remember yeah
you're the question um this is a
question for you well mostly you key arm
but so about a week ago I attended to
talk with Angela Davis and she talked
about how art specifically music can be
a way of healing especially in times of
like burning out and just like in
disrupting and like the emotional toll
that can have them students how do you
see like art as a way of like in your
terms of like breaking it and sort of
like breaking things that were
accustomed to as sort of like healing so
the question was about here Cory want to
come hang at the podium with me um so
the question was about art at music in
particular having healing qualities and
what's the relationship between those
healing qualities and the disruption
disruptive qualities of art and you know
I've thought a lot about that and I
actually was going to put in here
something about the healing legacy that
I come from but I didn't because I
thought it went a little bit off topic
but I'll say this I think about I also
come from an agricultural in a gardening
legacy and what I have learned from the
elder women in my family some of whom
are no longer with us that they learned
from their elders was about the tool
that we call a hoe right so how is it
has like it's on like a mop handle and
it's got a blade at the end of it and
you literally break the earth right and
you break the earth in order to create
troughs narrow troughs where what goes
in the troughs seeds and so I think this
relationship between breaking and
healing isn't necessarily dichotomous I
think it's symbiotic and circular and so
I think the same music that can be
disruptive can also be healing and I
know music has healed me my entire life
and one of the reasons that I asked
Corey about what music he was listening
to as a kid because I knew it'd be a way
for me to just understand get into his
life get into his mind you know that and
I've heard about some of the music that
I was listening to too does that make
sense
Corie um did you know what the story was
today or was that the first time you're
hearing it or how do you feel about
hearing your story but well if she's
talking about events that actually
happened in my life and not so much the
whole thing with the glass breaker thing
but prior so you know as you live life
and you you grow in your della develop
you tend to forget certain things and
how how you felt at that time about
certain things happening like just
hearing her mentioned you know fourth of
July my family getting together I had
warned Brooke both sides of my family
everybody a harmony nobody arguing the
what point if I just having a good time
you know those that suspects my
childhood in being 41 you know you tend
to forget what it was like when you were
seven because you get caught up in your
daily grind of this and that net and it
it was just it was just humbling to hear
her speak about my childhood in
different things that I went through
growing up so um no I didn't know
exactly what she was gonna say but it
was good to hear can you talk a little
about the process that you went through
in terms of just like generating this
people and just sort of like how you
went about asking questions and that
work of it and then also just how this
relates to your work as a playwright and
how that intersects with this story sure
so well one point that Corey and I spoke
about last week was how the the students
who were freshmen
during this event are now going to
graduate this year and so next year it
will be a completely new group of
students we were just wondering you know
what what does the story mean when it's
a totally new group of students anyway
that's a bit of a tangent but basically
as I mentioned in the story it really
blew up in the media Cory was his lawyer
Patricia's here today and
I think she helped like set him up with
the phone so that he could field all
these interviews at the time and so
that's how I heard about it I heard
about it in the press actually it wasn't
me who heard about it was my husband and
he called me from work and he's a public
defender so he was he's like interested
in matters of like the Criminal Court
and so he called me he was like this
happened this is gonna be your next play
this is what you have to write about and
so I was like oh okay so let me check it
out and and so I checked it out and he
was like the hearing is like in two days
you have to go up you have to go up and
so I went up and I was like my allowed
to go in so he he was like yeah you can
go and I don't you know I Corey gave
this interview on Democracy Now
it's a really interesting interview and
I that's how I started to learn his his
action became a gateway for me to learn
more about the history of slavery with
the American College System and with Ivy
League schools there was a scholar on
there talking about about the history
who was very knowledgeable in the
history so I went and read his book and
I saw that interview and to me Cory was
magnetic I was just like I like him I
want to meet him I want to look him in
the eye I just want to see how this
proceeding goes so I went up and I've
taken a little break from playwriting
now but I was like in the thick of it
then and so I was like I was nervous one
of the first things I talked about with
Corey was you know I'm a light-skinned
latina you know you're a black man we're
connected by this institution like how
do we feel about me interviewing you and
writing the story and we had those sort
of conversations Cory seemed less
nervous about that component than I was
so we plan to write a play and four
years later you know this is what came
of those conversations I came up to New
Haven a few times we had some meals I
was really just interested in like what
his life was like just converse a
the thing I love about playwriting is I
always write like this but I've never
done outside of my family this is the
first time I've written outside of my
family in terms of I'm just sitting down
with the junior at the Oh George and
being like so tell me about how you got
interested in gardening and then a whole
history of someone's life opens up in a
way that would never have in casual
conversation if you didn't sit someone
down and say I just want to listen to
you for a few hours are cool with that
so this was and still feels new for me
you know and then I guess Cory and I can
like chat on the phone tomorrow and see
what we thought and where we might want
to take it from here I thought it I have
a commission from Lincoln Center Theater
and so I thought it would be a kind of
wild topic to bring that's a very very
it's like one of the wealthiest theatre
audiences in New York and I've been
really nervous to write to play for them
because I don't know it's in theater it
can be very weird to have like a super
wealthy audience watching some of the
topics I deal with it feels like there's
a dissonance and I can be very
disturbing to me but then I was like
well maybe this is an opportunity to
really actually engage that dissonance
and be speaking directly to that
audience
and anyway that those are some of the
ramblings do you have anything to add no
not really this is just a fascinating to
me how how people are as a connected you
know you know University is our common
link but if you read more into it we
both have a lot of similarities in our
upbringing and the lives we live you
know so this is history and it's
interesting to see how people actually
connect with each other like people you
would never sit down and try to have a
conversation with but you got a lot in
common
I'm starting to understand now is the
more I write about it what the 80s and
90s meant I didn't understand it at the
time we were young I'm 42 we really did
come of age at the same time different
cities different neighborhoods but part
of telling this story especially like my
part of the story
was thinking about like what were the
you know the historic influences and and
you know trends that we're affecting my
life and I didn't even know it I just
thought oh my god why is everything so
messed up and this isn't fairer and that
sort of thing that's how it felt at the
time I first I want to thank you both
for an extraordinary presentation this
question is for you Cory and I hope I
can pull together these thoughts one of
the things that one of the privileges
that being here as a student at Yale
which believe it or not I am as well an
undergraduate confers on us is that we
are given the stamp of approval we are
given a sense that our our words are
going to matter and will be paid
attention to and your your story your
extraordinary story will now be heard as
it absolutely should I want to ask you
if Kiara had not found you tracked you
down sat you down I mean others did
democracy now many other places but
those are very fleeting the news today
over tomorrow did you where would your
story
how would your story have been preserved
and did you recognize within yourself
that you're a hero I you know we all you
know we've been trained to sort of know
oh there's the story I'm going to write
a play I'm going to make a painting I'm
going to do a mural I'm going to write a
book I find myself thinking today that
the world is celebrating marking
mourning the death of a 41 year old man
who is acknowledged as a heroic
african-american figure and in certain
ways that's obviously true but to me
you're the you're the 41 year old
african-american
hero whose
contribution is enduring in in this most
powerful way
would you have simply gone back to the
dining hall and never felt a need to
never felt that your story had to go out
into the world well I'm a journalism
major
okay so I have writing ability I'm also
a she was procrastinator the story is
already written in my heart and in my
mind it's just a matter of sitting down
right in the story he's been saying that
from the first time we talked he's like
I want to write a book I want to write
it you know it's like I forgot to ask
you last time we spoke but you had been
talking about like potentially writing a
play you know so you know being a
procrastinator just isn't another
qualification for being a writer so I
think I think one more question and then
we have a reception there's gonna be a
reception afterwards like we can keep
keep the conversation going
it's all yeah hi I'd like to thank you
both very much it's a very moving
presentation my question is the instant
that you broke the window what was going
through your mind I imagine that I
project on you that it was very
complicated or was it sort of a blind
rash impulsive time it was very
impulsive um you know the guides the
reunion alone who pointed it out to me
that happened like a Sunday and uh I
came back to work Monday and I did it on
Tuesday so it was uh that sounds fast
but it was a couple of days where it was
like I don't know you got calm I don't
know I don't want to like sound like I'm
crazy
and your mind you go through and um and
my mind always convinced myself know
what I'll be stupid why would you know
just no but in that moment something
just overcame and we had a nine ten
o'clock breathe a 10-minute break excuse
me
from nine and nineteen it wasn't that
moment in that time I just was like you
know nothing needs to come down and I
just did it impulsively
um I obviously didn't think about my
children or my own well-being because if
I had I probably would not have done
that but uh I have a lot of knowledge
but I don't always go off of what's the
word the intelligence of situations
sometimes I go off the a hard feeling
you know how does it make me feel what
do I really need to do in this situation
you know sometimes situations call for
you not to do the most logical thing in
order to accomplish things that was one
instance and it just happened to work
out for me it could have been disasters
I could be on the street begging for
money right now we never know but God
had my back and he made sure everything
over alpha me and say I'm most grateful
I think that's a beautiful place
actually to end and keep the
conversation going out in the reception
so thank you all
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]